OK.
Let's now discuss the crowd at Donald Trump's
rally.
Donald Trump's campaign was hugely trolled
on Saturday night, and the story really bears
telling because it is so emblematic of how
the Trump administration and Trump campaigner
mismanaged and also of how easily triggered
and thin skinned Donald Trump and his followers
are.
So the venue where they held the rally had
a maximum capacity of 19000.
Donald Trump and his campaign manager and
a whole bunch of other people were insisting
we've had hundreds of thousands of ticket
requests.
We've had a million tickets requested.
We are not going to be able to fill the requests.
There's too much demand.
So many people want to go.
This will be a historically huge rally and
it couldn't possibly have gone more embarrassingly
wrong in terms of attendance.
So, first of all, the signs that things weren't
going so well were when they started putting
together this overflow stage, which Donald
Trump believed that they would need.
And the overflow stage was for all the people
who would show up and not be able to get in.
In other words, people in excess of the 19000
that could fit in the stadium.
So they were going to do sort of like a separate
speech for the overflow crowd.
Maybe have Mike Pence address them, maybe
have Trump talk to them.
Nobody was there.
They shut down the entire overflow area while
the rally was still going on.
Secret Service clearing the area and breaking
down the American flags and crowd control
barriers just not even necessary.
But here's the genius part, and we're still
trying to figure out the details on this.
There have been a few different ways this
has been presented.
It appears as though when this event was announced
and ticket requests became available, the
form that you fill out was it was made available.
People not just from all over the country,
but all over the world started requesting
a ton of tickets to make the Trump campaign
believe that there was just overwhelming demand
to go to this Korona rally and watch Trump
speak to a huge crowd.
And this was the source of Trump's campaign
manager, Brad Paşa Scale, claiming that a
million people want to go to this event.
But in the end, the fire department says,
sixty two hundred people went.
The capacity was 19000.
The entire upper level was almost completely
empty.
Much of the floor area was completely empty.
And by the way, imagine camping out all week
when in reality you could have just walked
up on the day of and gotten right into this
stupid rally.
Now, I do want to be crystal clear, because
I don't want people to think.
I just want to.
I don't want to send mixed signals is the
point.
I don't even think this rally should have
been held from the pope from the perspective
of Corona virus.
And we should all be glad that sixty 200 people
instead of 19000 are sixty two thousand were
there.
That will save lives.
There will be people who don't get the virus
and some who don't die because Donald Trump's
rally completely flopped versus if the stadium
had been full.
So I'm glad from a public health standpoint
that this happened.
I'm glad from a political standpoint as well.
But the degree of embarrassment for the Trump
campaign is absolutely stunning.
Stunning.
Here is Donald Trump saying we've never had
an empty seat and we're not going to have
one in Oklahoma.
This was just a few days ago.
He's done a great job.
Oklahoma's at a very low number.
They've done a really fantastic work.
They have a new, pretty new, magnificent arena,
as you probably have heard.
And we're getting exact numbers out, but we're
either close to or over one million people
wanting to go.
We have a twenty two thousand seat arena.
But I think we're going to also take the convention
hall next door.
And that's going to hold 40000.
So of 22000 plus 40000, which would be that
would have over nine hundred thousand people
that won't be able to go.
But hopefully they'll be watching.
But it's it's an amazing nobody's ever heard
a numbers like this.
I think we're going to have we're gonna have
a great time.
We're going to talk about our nation.
How funny is that?
Trump saying between the arena and the overflow.
We're going to have more than 60000 people.
They had 60, 200.
Here's a bunch of people associated with Trump
claiming that a million people signed up for
the rally.
It's going to be huge.
The first person is governors tip from Oklahoma.
Take a look.
Like you said, I don't know.
People caught that.
But over a million people have requested tickets
to come to come to this event.
Look, I think your evidence, though, by saying
one million ticket requests for this rally
in Tulsa.
I think it's time they're so excited about
it that you have no idea.
And we have had so many sign ups.
You know, there are lines of people now and
we won't be there for three days.
They have lines of people right now trying
to get into the arena.
I mean, they'll be there.
They'll be early.
How many people be one of those early front
rows?
How many people signed up, do you know?
Over a million people requested tickets.
Well, there's just a hunger for the rallies.
And so you have this massive crowd.
You have nearly a million tickets that are
demand are demanded out there.
People pree filling out their applications
and what not to come in.
What are you going to do with all these people
that literally could be hundreds of thousands
of people trying to come and you've only got
19000 seats indoors.
What about all those other people?
What are you going to do with them?
Well, there is an overflow crowd, but it really
is a testament to how people are ready to
move on and especially in Oklahoma.
Hearing the word, especially from a governor,
is always a little jarring.
But the really jarring thing is that they
were expecting hundreds of thousands of people
to show up in support of Donald Trump.
And six, the two hundred showed up a third
of the arena's capacity.
And that is good.
We should all be glad because of how much
better that is in terms of corona virus.
They sort of tried to make it a little less
embarrassing by claiming 12000 people were
there.
But again, the fire department is good at
estimating crowd size.
They said it was 60, 200 people.
Now, there are rumors that Donald Trump is
furious with his campaign manager, Brad Parr
scale.
We're going to talk more about that later.
How could par scale let Trump be this embarrassed?
Here is Trump when he landed from the rally
that night, looking extremely tired, low energy,
not happy.
And I mean, listen, would you be happy if
after all this buildup room for sixty two
thousand, including the overflow area, a million
suppose ticket requests and you go and there
are sixty two hundred people and the entire
thing is mocked endlessly.
I'd also be furious.
Now, one other thing.
Some on the right tried claiming that attendance
was lower than expected because of anti Trump
protesters.
OK, the framing was hundreds of thousands
of people.
Sixty thousand people, a million people did
want to go.
But because of these violent and aggressive
liberals that showed up and intimidated Trump
ists. Trump has stayed away.
Number one, if you have a million people that
want to go in 60, 200, show up, you're saying
that, you know, ninety nine point whatever
percent of Trump ists are dissuaded from going
to support their dear leader by some silly
liberal snowflakes who don't even carry guns
showing up what the rugged conservatives are
going to say.
Sorry, I'm not going to go see our lord and
savior in person because of these little liberals
that showed up.
That's actually the claim that you're making.
Of course, it's complete and total B.S.
And what I mean to show you next are some
clips of Trump campaign staff humiliated when
trying to explain away what happened here.